nasa's rover perseverance made its
gentle touchdown on the red planet
after traveling nearly 500 million
kilometers
its mission to search for signs of life
a first look after a nearly 500 million
kilometer journey to subsonic
speeds and the heat shield has been
separated the removal of the heat shield
was preceded by the opening of the
perseverance's parachute
the planet's rust-colored terrain drew
ever closer
and after a few tense minutes the
seven-month wait was finally over
touchdown confirmed perseverance
faithfully
on the surface of mars ready to begin
seeking the sands of past life
perseverance will gather rock and soil
samples but
images like these will also allow the
public to share in the excitement of the
mission
and these are pretty cool videos and we
will learn something
by looking at the performance of the
vehicle in these videos but a lot of it
is also
to bring you along uh on our journey our
touchdown to mars and of course
our surface mission as well in addition
to video footage
the rover has also already transmitted
the first recording of sound on the
planet
a gust of wind heard across the galaxy
[Music]
the rover is also beaming back photos
from the martian surface
as it collects and stores samples it's
hoped that they could be brought back to
earth by return mission
in the early 2030s the vista here that
we
were
you